there's a bar I go to quite a lot uh
whenever I want to go out to drink with
people the guy's so chill he's so nice
yeah one dude runs it plays smooth jazz
and it's just one dude and then one time
this is where I felt like we'd we bonded
in a weird way I was like hey can I
borrow your charger and he was like of
course bro he gave it to me and I was
like it's a real one it's a real woman
real friends like you borrow their
charge I'm coming back I'm coming back
in Japan this is like I said there's a
weird thing about people like not
wanting to let people use like
electrical sockets or yeah use like
electricity of a business I don't know
it depends like they're just really
chill about it yeah I feel I feel most
of those like small bar places so we're
best friends now yeah I feel a lot of
the small bar places they don't really
care but if it's like you know a an
establishment where it's like they're
trying to make money they're trying to
make this business lucrative then
they're like oh I mean you could borrow
my charger and uh you know put me up an
extra 50 Yen on my electricity bill but
you should probably order three
cocktails first it's like okay that
doesn't seem fair but sure first one
drink they just don't want to be in
there yeah they just want you to order a
drink drink it get the [__] I think it's
just asking for any requests that's off
the script of the Japanese menu you know
and I I guess I guess that's just true
for a lot of establishments in Japan
where there's not a lot of better menus
yeah a lot of bars like what do you want
no I mean like bars are different like
asking for asking for a request that's
off like what they have listed in their
mental checklist if you went to a size
area and you asked like oh can I borrow
the charger the waitress will probably
be [__] herself like it's like this
is not I did not learn yeah what to say
in this situation you can literally see
them like socially blue screen yeah just
like oh once you hear that then you know
this is a blue screen yeah yeah I kind
of realized how much I'd forgotten I'd
like kind of like taken just like that
kind of like little thing for granted
until I go to a place outside of Japan
like I remember in Australia
uh this was I think like last year when
uh we were flying back or something and
I'd stayed like a few extra days to stay
with family
uh I had booked so we're in Melbourne
and I had booked a plane uh not from
Melbourne Airport uh Melbourne Airport
but I did not know the difference
between Melbourne Airport and I think
Avalon is that like the other
there's one main airport yeah and then
there's one in the [__] ton like middle
of nowhere yeah where you have to drive
like two hours or some [__] like yeah
it's a domestic airport yeah it's a
domestic airport I didn't know I just
chose an airport right uh and I didn't
know that this was the shitty airport
that basically only I think Jetstar or
something like yeah fly out there
and so I didn't know that
and so what happens is I had like uh I
had a I had a SIM card which was my
British SIM cards uh so he could receive
texts but the data was a little bit
spotty right welcome to Australia yeah
welcome to Australia so we I was in this
[__] Uber
um driving to this airport that was an
hour out we were 45 no we're like
halfway there
right and it was the only flight flying
to Sydney that day
I don't know why I thought there would
be more flights lines as I need that day
and uh halfway to this airport I get a
text being like your flight has been
canceled and I'm like
[__] what what am I supposed to do I'm
like halfway to this airport
uh I don't have a flight there that I
know there's not going to be any other
flights there so I've just gotta go back
to the city so I like tell the Uber
driver hi I noticed I know it's really
bad but can you turn around and uh drop
us off back uh you know back in
Melbourne and we'll figure it out there
and he's like sure all you need to do is
just add in a new destination uh on the
Uber app yeah problem is I got no data
yeah I can make and receive calls but I
got no data yeah yes like welcome to
welcome to the 21st century if you don't
have internet you are [__] yeah uh and
I'm like [__] what can I do so we saw
like I saw like [__] panicking
because he's like I cannot I cannot
change the destination on my app you
have to be the one to change the
destination uh so I'm like okay let's uh
let's look for a place that might have
free Wi-Fi not knowing forgetting that
uh outside of major cities Australia
there's no internet Australia is
apparent Wasteland yeah that has no
[__] internet so so I'm trying to
look for like a rest stop or something
and we're driving for like another like
10 minutes
thankfully we see a convenience store I
think it's a I think it was like a
7-Eleven yeah uh and I'm like [__] [__]
[__] I'm hoping that Japan like
Australia is kind of like Japan or
America where they have public Wi-Fi at
every [__] convenience store like
public
no no
they do in Japan really they do in Japan
in a lot of places well you have data in
Japan yeah like every parking area has
like free Wi-Fi yeah I don't know that
yeah so we pull up to the 7-Eleven and I
go up to the cashier I'm like uh mate do
you have uh do you have a like public
Wi-Fi here and he's like what's Wi-Fi
yeah and he's like sorry mate oh like we
don't have we don't have Wi-Fi here and
I'm like [__] I'm in kind of a bind
right now and like I explained my
situation and he's like oh no worries
I'll start tethering all my fun I've got
I got data here and I'm like [__]
hell I've forgotten I'd forgotten what
this feeling was like being like hey you
forgot that people are helpful yeah I'm
like hey I'm in a bind I know how I have
a strange request right now yeah but uh
do you have any public Wi-Fi because I'm
kind of [__] if uh if you don't uh and
he's like don't worry mate I got you
covered I don't like [__] this this has
never happened to me in Japan where I'm
just in a bind and you have a request
that's kind of like out of left field
and uh people actually respond to that
and uh we'll try to help you what if you
just will [__] you with him he's like
hold on I gotta like these tweets first
all right oh yeah oh yeah yeah right
right yeah that's right yeah so thank
you 7-Eleven person I've random seven
seven eleven person in Melbourne you are
yeah you saved me literally like two
hours of my life just will be able to do
wait why don't you go to the normal
Apple there's like it's like a flight to
Sydney every like two minutes because uh
when I booked it I didn't know that
there were two words also why did you
not ask the Ubi driver if you could
borrow his tether
[Music]
that was a reason why he couldn't tether
and I can't remember why because he was
driving maybe but I did ask him because
I I'm like I tried to go through every
engineering route to solve this issue
and I can't remember the reason why he
couldn't tether but yeah he couldn't
feel like that maybe he was an [__]
I want the uh full charge for me going
to this airport then going back yeah
there was uh yeah because like I think
it's really normal for some reason that
flights between Melbourne and Sydney get
canceled or delayed well if from regular
Melbourne Airport they this is like a
flight that leaves every 30 minutes yeah
even if it does get canceled it's not a
big issue I mean Kai was sitting in uh
like Lounge waiting and there was like
six flights in the next like three hours
yeah and like half of them got canceled
yeah and I there's like no explanation
why yeah and so I think ours got pushed
back and it made my transfer really
tight made it from like an hour and a
half to like 30 minutes and I was like
oh I don't I don't really feel like
risking it and there's a flight coming
up in like 40 minutes and I was like
well I'll just go ask if I can go on
that one I was like hey can I just go on
this flight and they were like yeah I
was like oh really they're like yeah oh
okay cool thanks so I went on that
flight
I literally just went up and I was like
hey uh I got a tight connection I just
go on the one that's coming up in like
20 minutes yeah that would never happen
in Japan yeah it says [__] no